[Musica]
mi fa molto strano essere su questo
palco come come cecilia vecchio perché
salire come sicilia vecchio non è come
salirci con con un personaggio sapere
una parte a memoria e parlare con altri
attori che portano altri personaggi sì
ho fatto anche dei monologhi ma sempre
con una maschera ma se avete appunto
come sentito mi ha presentato stefano ha
detto anche cose che io di solito
preferisco non dire della televisione sì
sì perché noi lo chiamiamo il lato
oscuro noi teatranti si ironicamente
percy lavoro ma con la televisione ma
soprattutto io sono orgogliosa di dire
che sono un'attrice teatrale
essendo un'attrice age se lo sono sembra
tra scenica diciamo 40 anni ho alle
spalle parecchi i palchi di parecchi
generi e io ho sempre sospettato che
questo sarebbe stato il mio destino ma
quello che non sapevo è che questo
lavoro mi avrebbe fatto sentire
lecita cioè io uso questa parola ma ci
ho messo anni a trovarla è una parola
molto importante per me perché io prima
camminavo per le strade sui marciapiedi
e sulle spiagge sentieri di montagna
locali discoteca ovunque ma io non mi
sentivo mai adatta ero sempre sbagliata
fuori misura
perdonatemi la battuta brutta non sono
però è quello che spesso mi veniva detto
e tranquilli adesso io non sono qui per
parlare dei miei problemi col mio peso
con non ho ne ho già parlato e speso
tantissimi soldi con tantissimi
psicoterapeuti che ringrazio e saluto in
diretta ma non sono qua per questo ma
quello che accade quando un attrice
frantuma il suo io non è mia questa
questa è di luigi pirandello
sì perché noi in teatro così ci diamo
tutti del tu come una così finta
parentela cioè tipo non lo so e giorgio
strehler toni servillo è così insomma
quando l'attrice
toglie questa maschera questo io entra
in un'altra maschera
il palcoscenico diventa come un tappeto
volante
davvero che ti porterà in mondi
paralleli è così che è accaduto a me
sin dalla prima volta che sono andata in
scena tutti i mondi in cui siamo andati
io e le mie maschere siamo state felici
davvero se passeggiando per vittorio
emanuele mirano asilo sono di milano
sentivo sguardi giudicanti derisori
battute risate così che mi arrivavano
come frecce infuocate nel profondo
quando iniziava lo spettacolo io ero
felice era tutto più facile
i miei personaggi erano leciti e io
diventavo più potente e tutti mi
ammiravano e mi sentivo molto più forte
avevo questa forza e ora io mi sono
detta ma perché no ma certo c'è perché
non portare la mia realtà sul palco
giusto e così è stato
mi sono creata una maschera meravigliosa
un po da supereroe il mio alter ego
evelina creata con andrea narsi che è un
drammaturgo attore per me eccezionale
con cui lavoro da anni diciamo mi sono
affidata a lui e così è nato il giorno
di evelina 24 ore da di per sé così la
mia realtà è andata in scena con una
maschera da supereroe pontida e rovina
come era evelina e subito le luci che mi
che mi prendevano e che mi esponevano
sono diventate le mie alleate
allora velina è coraggiosa racconta le
sue fragilità e le sue paure il suo
dolore suo problema col cibo tutte
queste cose qua evelina però ha dato un
po di forza anche a cecilia ea tante
cecilia come lei e il pubblico la amava
io lei era un'insegnante di un
insegnante di scuola materna aveva amici
amiche viveva da sola alla sabato
pomeriggio se ne andava al supermercato
lotta con il carrello lotta con il
cioccolatino e la sera se ne andava nei
locali e doveva camminare sulla pista in
mezzo ai suoi demoni e poi la notte in
casa da sola col frigorifero
mefistofelico e la bilancia
psicoterapeuta severa
abbiamo organizzato
post spettacoli degli incontri li dopo
proprio dello spettacolo in platea
soprattutto durante le mattine coi
ragazzi con gli psicologi del gruppo di
massimo recalcati che ai tempi non era
ancora noto e durante le mattine e
appunto io eravamo spiegavamo ma nessuno
diceva niente nessuna donna domanda
nessun dubbio niente ma poi
venivano tutti in camerino
tutte maschi femmine e si mettevano in
coder tipo rockstar che volevano parlare
con evelina perché era entrata nei loro
cuori ea lei dicevano tutto quello che
sentivano
evelina non era sola e ma non lo era
nemmeno cecilia però da qua le cose si
sono evolute e veline partita ha
cominciato a girare per l'italia per la
svizzera per la polonia fino ad arrivare
a cuba
eh sì perché lì c'era un festival che si
chiamava quarto con un titolo così non
poteva non andare giusto allora sono
arrivata ed era organizzata
da questa compagnia di danza
contemporanea over size danza voluminosa
incredibile come non dire si può fare
spero che c'è una citazione sia arrivata
comunque una compagnia dove le
danzatrici erano come me obese
colmavano quel palco come dei pasticcini
in un vassoio una accanto all'altra ne
potevi sentire anche l'odore della
grassa
questa è una citazione dello spettacolo
di velina l'ho rubata perdonarla perché
per rendervi conti come stavamo su quel
palco e io non ci potevo credere mi
sentivo pinocchio con con lucignolo
andrea narsi nel paese dei balocchi io
cecilia vecchio al teatro nazionale
dell'avana dopo dove un mese prima fidel
castro aveva dato il commiato alla sua
popolazione
io
ballavo con altre dieci ballerine con
questi splendidi corpi morbidi
morbidissimi tonici che si muovevano
volteggiavano e udite udite
venivano sollevati
da danzatori normali cioè come ve
l'immaginate poi cubani figurate
comunque non è questo è che in italia
a me hanno chiesto di sollevare un
danzatore che questa la cosa sbagliata
io invece cosa ho fatto
prima hanno fatto fare chiama già l'idea
del mare io che camminava e ballavo in
mezzo a queste onde del mare immaginarie
io credo che almeno una volta nella vita
a tutte le donne dovrebbero sentirsi
così scusate mi emoziono quando penso a
quelle cose mi succede sempre
e poi è stato il momento di evelina e se
abbiamo raccontato la sua storia anche a
loro un po in italiano un po di spagnolo
pochito depan unica cosa faceva dire
sembrava veneto però spagnolo osannata
applaudita
cioè lacrime di gioia di comprensione
una cosa incredibile
insomma
evelina aveva svolto la sua missione
aveva lanciato la palla cecilia e ora
bisognava alzare il tiro giusto e la mia
forza
aveva bisogno di essere rafforzata di
essere alimentata e una nuova moda che
era arrivata come sempre dal passato mi
diede uno stimolo nuovo
potevo dimostrare che ogni donna poteva
essere accattivante dolce affascinante e
divertente e cosa poteva essere se non
il burlesque
e burlesque poche parole burlesque e è
un'antica
spettacolo della metà dell'ottocento
della inghilterra vittoriana e si
traduce in uno spettacolo
che dall'ironia riva alla satira e
prendendo in giro prendeva in giro alle
compagnie allora in voga ai ceti sociali
altri
insomma le classi dirigenti e un atto
burlesque che in italiano si c'e burla e
parte da una maschera che
raccontando la sua storia a un certo
punto c'è un punto di rottura pam e si
spoglia di tutto
quindi e burlesque
libera le donne dal perbenismo e dal
fatto che bisogna essere affascinanti
per gli uomini e non per se stesse e
invece uno sberleffo che che fa
aumentare l'autostima tira la
consapevolezza del tuo corpo e smetti di
farti sentire inadatta e tutto
conoscendo così il tuo corpo è tutto più
facile
quindi io sono qua a dire spogliarsi fa
bene si toglie la maschera e ci si
libera delle maschere che mettiamo ogni
giorno ogni ambiente ogni ambito a una
maschera
insomma e curativo
io non sono mai riuscita a togliere
alcuni indumenti
questo non sono mai riuscita ma quello
che so che sono riuscita a togliermi
quelli che mi sono serviti per
ritrovarmi a quelli li ho trovati
poi mi è stato chiesto di fare dei
workshop di burlesque e si sono
presentate doni di ogni genere e di ogni
età fisicità ceto sociale e tutte che
volevano sentirsi donne aiutami a
sentirmi donna sentirsi lecite come
l'insegnate io sono contentissimo è
stata un'esperienza magica e mettere a
nudo
un'intimità che
è legittimata
sarà così accettata nella sua diversità
è questa la cosa importante è importante
essere diversi essere unici irripetibili
e la cosa straordinaria
questo credo di averlo sempre pensato ma
il teatro me l'ha dato come come stile
di vita
ogni ogni maschera è diversa ogni
personaggio è diverso ogni donna ogni
corpo e tutti possono essere velina
vedo avevo se faccio un po perplesse lo
so e fosse parlato un po teatrale un po
poetico forse un po troppo lontano
perché le cose sono un po cambiate negli
ultimi anni per fortuna
ora si parla di di questo problema che
prima non c'era
si parla più liberamente le donne sono
più consapevoli e sanno che non devono
avere paura e poi è stata creata una
terminologia
tipo
body positive non so se l'avete mai
sentita l'avete già sentita
sapete che cos'è e bosi positive è un
movimento che sostiene le persone che
non sono rappresentate
da dai media soprattutto ma soprattutto
in questo momento sta lottando
per insegnare alla gente che la parola
grassa non è
dispregiativa è un aggettivo massa basta
alta bionda bruna grassa io sono grassa
ma non è dispregiativo è che lui è
diventato poi c'è la parola curvi che è
diciamo forte della moda dalla 46 alla
52 poi c'è plus size che ed al 52 in più
e poi c'è la mia preferita body shameen
la conoscete
finalmente finalmente questa parola
esiste il problema c'è
mo di shame in atto di deridere o
discriminare una persona per il suo
aspetto fisico
allora avevo ragione io eh sì quando mi
dicevano ma dai come se ma figurati
mudry stavo solo scherzando ma non ti
preoccupare
come sei pesante vi giuro questa battuta
mi è stata detta e ridetta e stradetta
eppure così adesso esiste body shameen
evelina mi ha insegnato ad amarmi a
imparare ad amarvi e insegnarvi ad
amarmi
è una cosa incredibile però è così il
social ora sono piene di e veline che
mettono il loro corpo
mostrano il loro corpo ballano danzano
saltano fanno sobbalzare il loro corpo
mostrano le loro nudità e lo fanno con
orgoglio
però io ricordo sempre questa cosa è
grasso è bello
troppo e faticoso questo non bisogna mai
dimenticarlo
e credo che velina e quelle come lei che
hanno il coraggio di esporsi
loro hanno imparato a non avere paura è
questa la cosa importante e di non avere
paura di quello che si è
magari la maschera e la persona sono
cose diverse ma una non esiste se non
c'è l'altra è la maschera e piu vera
perche e finzione e perché ti porta
qualsiasi cosa in maniera goliardica
la realtà invece porta tanta menzogna
soprattutto la maschera ti porta delle
cose che per alcune persone sono
inaccettabili e la maschera tra la rende
accettabile per esempio il giullare di
corte
lui può prendere in giro quanto vuole il
re lui accetterà lo scherno perché
perché una maschera
comunque sia la maschera che la persona
rendono un mondo migliore
buon teatro a tutti
[Applauso]